wird man gerade wo bist du ich bin
gerade bei mir zu hause habe ich jetzt
wieder zurück zur rüdiger bei dir zu
hause das manchmal überhaupt das thema
gesprochen aber wir haben schon 1000
darüber kannst du deine meinung sein
meine meinung wenn die zuschauer schon
ja ich habe ich bin der meinung frauen
hinterm herd ist sondern die nicht mehr
können die nicht nein sie also ich bin
der meinung frauen sollten halt wissen
wo ihr platz ist frau saß werde wo ist
also meine freunde die spiele sims und
habe diese richtiger club meine meine
schwester babette jetzt jedoch nicht
ganz wettmachen konnte jetzt zum
schlafen
ich komme ich durch die tür öffnete ich
bin drin drin
so stoppt trinken gehen am bett gehüpft
ihr haus nutzt
ich glaube das paket ist
ich glaube ich nicht hin so war somit
das zusammen hast du etwa eingebaut
also haus ist ja auch gerade vor
wiederum gar nicht ich lache das hast du
gut gemacht
ich mache mal den smiley hier so gerne
die deutsche wehrmacht die zwar nicht so
oft erst bei liga total
ich hatte ja diesen smiley den smiley
hat sich auch zwingend so wichtig des
zwingers weil ich habe eine freundin
erklärt dass wir nicht machen da für
mich gemacht und ich hatte auch die
frauen machen männer nicht blinker
smiley des komisch ekelhaft solche kraft
dass ich möchte irgendwie irgendwie
möchte ich möchte ich in diesem werk da
wir was bauen rate ich habe hier so
komische heek instituts gehabt werd ich
bau dir einfach hierhin und schaue was
daraus wird
wo möchte ja du kannst ja auch im
bergbau es ist egal ich mache so ein
händler
ich mach' ich mache so eine richtig
schöne treppe hinab wir auch nach brand
aber weißt was ich und schwach so ein
tunnel system zu dem haus angegriffen
richtig erweisen wäre der babbels was
was wenn mutti nicht drauf ist
ja das wäre blöd wenn man so viele bäume
hätte ein stark bläst vor allem die
bäume hier sind richtig fett
ich bin im schlaf rauben bei einem
solchen abbauen
spitzhacke ist ganz gut vom baum
diamante am besten damit noch mehr erde
kennen aus wenn ich genug abfließen wird
er vor bohlens termin steht die drei mal
angeguckt weil man muss damit leben
können drei mal angeguckt angehört
angeschaut also video die nutzer als
wenn du den film an gehört hast ja ich
hab mir das video der verankerung weil
das lieblingslied das video roll
haftbefehl darum auf jeden fall da sind
so richtig viele bedeutet geht damit
machen das dauert auch verlange also ich
find das sieht so die schilder einfach
nur rum im raum genau ich von der
aufmachung helfen spinnst und gemacht
was hat ein richtig guter stimmung so
wird's halt alles so ab sind aber auch
sterben jugend ist kaputt
mannschaft jetzt auch durchgeführt
ich finde werde ich hab mir vorgenommen
mich hiermit alle hoch zu bauen und dann
runter zu bauen also das hoch daumen
runter
es ist sehr klug wenn man sich erst dann
wieder runter baut also alle auf
ungespielt hören das ist die beste die
ich hier gehört haben müssen wir lachen
jetzt dachte ich wir sollten bild
münchen so ich brauche auf jeden fall
direkt an den pc doch das sehr schön und
da was nicht mehr drin
bevor wir richtig drin alle hüllen hier
wieder was irgendwie schon drin und
sogar fackeln wenn ich da rein gehen
will
du bist nur eigentlich gerade ja ich
gehe auf den baum drauf gleich kombi
chips zu kommen 100.000 black o nein
also bin ich froh ich habe zum glück
einer balkan-reise nackt machen wenn
meiner kaputt geht weil der baum
ich glaube ich hätte ganz ganz viele
brauchen diesen baum zu fällen ich
glaube diese toppt diese folge hier
werde ich nennen baumfäller wissen wer
der baumfäller ist oder wie er gesteht
ich bin oben drauf putin r club in den
geschäften
seht euch nur mein werk an so ich mache
jetzt nichts machen ich brauch holz er
ist nur der arzt war wir aus diesem wald
und schädigt aber trotzdem abreißen
jetzt abbauen
abhauen oder abbauen abbauen und danach
abhauen danach abhauen sehr gute taktik
ich finde einen baum ich fälle einen
baum und dieser baum heißt dann gefällt
so warte ich brauche colo colo colo colo
colo könne sein dass der koloss solche
maibaum ginge jetzt machen und dann
immer wenn der baum verlängern
dieses richtig hässlich ist mache ich
denn hier alles umsonst abgebaut
als nächstes mache ich mach den dieses
mal zum abo und fraktion zum holz das
feld weiter so stix unser leben lang
genug sticks welche abgeben wenn du
willst wenn ich will richtig gesetzt
ok gucken wir müssen handeln
und dann andere betroffene ist uns
einfach einen raum bauen ein haus wo wir
von beiden seiten reinigen kann und du
gehst man eine seite ich in die andere
wir müssen uns die sachen so geben wie
berichtet seit ich meine sinne unserer
kirche und in einer beschissenen damit
soll das einfach besser
wird nämlich nicht du hast doch schon
selber im inventar hat was ja die items
ja die chips in teheran zu denn nach der
kondom geplatzt ernst nein
doch weil ja also ich weiß nicht genau
wie protagonist dieses witzes rüdiger
liga also bis gestern nacht ein konter
geplatzt
was im ernst es gibt aber das ist mein
ernst hannover wo er ernst dieter blödes
wort ich kann man nur ernst wird was
nehmen
was würde das wäre so als würde ich
sagen im simon und luca beim einst das
im simon ja wirklich im simon geben sie
war mein kind noch ernst nehmen
so habe ich die ankläger ihren vollen
voll ernst die eltern ja ich bin grad
fast mein baum durch irgendwie dann
sitzt du das bitte schon dran
ich bin gerade weil die ganze erde
abzubauen aber es ist auch wirklich
großer form so soll man sagen die leute
hassen mich bestimmt nicht im akkord bin
schreibt ein fachkongress fazit herz
dahinter ich liebe das dass diese schau
für automatisches inventar gegen die
andere kaputt ist echt kult hat auch
diese achse ins inventar ich bekommen
habe ich mag es wenn die items
kaputtgemacht und morgen geräumt
das war so ein geräusch machen ja du
hast zwar kann
wir haben noch die mod eigentlich noch
gar nicht richtig ausgelöst außer obwohl
wir haben schon sehr viele sachen geholt
das stimmt ja wir werden auf jeden fall
ausnutzen aber ich sag mal
man soll den tag nicht lumpen lohnen
wird
wir wollen ja erst mal sowas schaffen
und erreichten damit wenn wir dann erst
mal mit langen haus haben können dann
machen genau das was du da bist du bei
uns in diesen märkten für diesen berg
hier david bowie oder und können so
einen treffer machen dann geht es mir
runter ich würde sagen dass wir jetzt
allgemein ich hab das in der türkei
schon mit denen macht ein riesiges feld
gebracht und das wird so geil aus und
das ist auch gut so funktion babbel
funktionsfähig also wieder verwertbar
seien tannen stamm can trust 57 energy
units glaube ich halten die ene nicht
euro danke dass ihr das incom der
extreme ich habe jetzt so viel holz also
blitz oder bin ich sehr viel holz aber
ich hab sehr viel erde also wir können
so ein bisschen tauschen dann okay aber
dann muss das erklären
das war ganz groß hat eine schöne textur
das ist einmal die vortex zu warten